Here's my solution.
I started with the original problem and
decided first to eliminate
this pesky free variable, x3, which
wasn't constrained to be nonnegative.
>From this equality constraint,
I know that x3 = x- 1 and
substituting that into the objective
function then gives me
that I need to minimize 4x1- 2x2.
There's some other constant out here,
but
that's not going to effect my choice for
the optimum value for x.
So, I can simply drop that.
We end up with 3x1 in
the inequality constraint.
And the -2 from this side,
increases the bound on the side to 7.
The equality constraint
goes away altogether,
with the elimination of the variable.
Now I need to turn this
inequality into an equality, so
I introduce a new slack variable, x3.
And then lastly, I just need to negate
the coefficients in the objective
function to convert the minimization
problem to a maximization problem.